the National Security Council Richard
Clarke and his new book is called your
government failed you thank you for
joining us this morning we want to get
the discussion underway with some of
your comments before the September 11th
Commission in 2004 so too the genesis
for the title of the book will give our
viewers a chance to look and and you can
comment after week let's take a look I
also welcome the hearings because it is
finally a forum where I can apologize
this 25 second to the loved ones of the
victims of 9/11 to them who are here in
the room to those who are watching on
television your government failed you
those entrusted with protecting you
failed you and I failed you we tried
hard but that doesn't matter because we
failed and for that failure
I would ask once all the facts are out
for your understanding and for your
forgiveness Richard Clarke what prompted
that apology before the 9/11 Commission
well I thought it was fairly
self-evident and obvious that the
government had failed and as a result of
that failure Americans and others had
died and I thought fairly natural under
those circumstances to to apologize I
know we we were charged we were the part
of the government the FBI the CIA
charged with preventing this sort of
thing and we didn't and as a result of
that people died I thought done and
rather obvious that you should apologize
your new book is your government failed
you write a lot about the Department of
Homeland Security how well have they
improved our domestic security since its
inception well that is the title of the
book your government failed you it's not
about 9/11 when I said your government
failed you
I assumed speaking about 9/11 that that
was a fair
a rare event in American history and I
assumed the failure is related to
terrorism and related issues would stop
after 9/11 and in fact there had been
many more failures and to some extent
even larger failures since 9/11 homeland
security I think is one of them frankly
yeah if you remember the history of the
creation of this department
it's the largest second largest
Department and the government largest
after the Defense Department President
Bush didn't like the idea I didn't like
the idea governor Ridge who would come
in after 9/11 into the White House
didn't like the idea either of creating
a department we're in the middle of
going after al-qaeda were in the middle
of reducing our vulnerabilities around
the country and people wanted to have us
focus on bureaucratic issues and in
Washington when you're doing a
reorganization of any size people focus
on where their desk is and do they have
a window with a view and who their boss
is and all of those things rather than
on the substance of the job so you want
to keep reorganization to a minimum and
what happened was that the Congress over
here wanted to do something want to be
seen to be doing something after 9/11
and so senator Lieberman was Democrat
the time proposed this department he
took recommendations from some
Commission's that had been studying
these issues and took those
recommendations pretty much lock stock
and barrel and they started to move a
bill and it was looking really good to
pass in the house and to pass in the
Senate with republicans voting forward
as well as Democrats and so we told the
president this his legislative affairs
people came up with with the head count
and they said oops and turned on a dime
from opposing the idea to saying it was
their idea and the president walked out
into the Rose Garden made the
announcement that he came up with this
brilliant idea and we should have a
Department of Homeland Security without
so much as referencing the fact that it
was Lieberman proposal so we had one
even though we didn't want one even
though we didn't think it was a good
idea and I don't think it's worked it
has a higher percentage of political
appointees than any department in the
entire federal government when it should
have had a lower percentage because it
should be a nonpartisan expert security
focused organization we want to get a
chance here to bring our c-span viewers
into the conversation numbers are on
your screen for Republicans 202 737
triple zero one Democrats 202 737 triple
zero two independents and all others 202
6 to 8 0 to 0-5 and outside the US
special line set aside two oh two six to
eight zero one eight four your book book
covers a lot of areas where the
government has failed you talk about the
Defense Department and talk about energy
and a number of other things but you
come from the background of a career
government employee who has seen a lot
of successes do you think the federal
government is a capable of that level of
success again not without some
fundamental changes I think that the
federal government has done some
marvelous things and people in politics
tend to use the federal government as a
political punching bag and they want to
run against the government want to run
against Washington want to run against
bureaucrats and they want to run against
regulation those are all bad words now
highly charged words bureaucrats
regulations federal government people
tend to forget because of all that
propaganda over many years what the
federal government has done and what it
does every day for them and the fact
that regulation and bureaucrats are
improving the quality of their lives and
when regulation and bureaucrats fail the
quality of the American life diminishes
what brought you into government service
to begin with and where'd you start I
started the Pentagon I was of an age
when Jack Kennedy became president and
called for us to join the government
he had a call for public service ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
not had an impression of my generation
let's hear from our callers Austin Texas
on a Republican line you're first up
with Richard Clarke visceral Parkton
you're against all enemies book YouTube
you wouldn't talk about America support
for Israel as being the root cause for
9/11 and James stanford conveys that in
a pretext for war book the wall to
marshana book on the Israel lobby can be
is that Texas we're gonna remind you of
a bar our policy thirty days please
refrain from calling good c-span program
given thirty days and give us a call
back Sandusky Ohio on our Democrats line
go ahead yes how you guys doing today
fine thanks hello c-span colors yes I
have three comments first off I tried to
call him when Scott McClellan was on on
the 30th my friend passed away in Iraq
war Charles old Odom's the second and he
had opportunity to face him I always my
second comment always felt like for last
weekend I would say that Scott McCullen
was like Luc Longley and and who knows
look Longley nobody does because he was
on Michael Jordan's team and won the
championship with him and Michael Jordan
is Bush nobody's talking about Michael
Jordan they're talking about Luc Longley
Scott McCullen so my third comment is
also I'll pick up on the last caller's
point could you answer his question it
seems like c-span didn't want to get
that question answered
now thank you very much sir yeah I'd be
glad to answer when whether the al Qaeda
started you know when bin Laden started
it in the late 1980s it's all throughout
the the 90s as it was building it talked
about Israel hardly at all
it's very different from Hamas and
Hizballah and the other Islamic
terrorist groups in that regard in that
al Qaeda really didn't care too much
about that issue in terms of what its
goal was its goal was not to overthrow
the Israeli government so much as to
overthrow Arabic go
his balith said that the people who were
running the governments of Egypt and
Saudi Arabia and these other countries
were apostates that they were phony
Muslims and they needed to be overthrown
and replaced by real Muslims ie them and
it wasn't until fairly late in the
nineteen nineties probably 98 done you
know and thereafter that bin Laden and
Zawahiri his deputy started to lace
their comments a little bit with
comments about Israel were you picking
this up when you were in the
counterterrorism oh yeah
yeah we we you know we're aware that
America's support for Israel which is
something that I support we're aware
that that causes people in the Islamic
world to be upset
but I don't think if the
palestinian-israeli problem disappeared
overnight if there were peace and
harmony throughout Israel and Palestine
and Syria and Jordan Lebanon they would
still be in al Qaeda
and it would still want to do what it
wants to do because that's really not
central to their beliefs Tampa Florida
is next and independent caller good
morning
good morning mr. Clark in 98 there was
legislation submitted to the Senate to
seal the cockpit doors on airliner and I
recall that that was based on the
intelligence we were receiving from 95
on could you tell us why that bill was
killed who killed that bill who was
behind it because talk about preemption
we could have preempted that's correct
and I'll hang up and listen thank you no
I'm not familiar with the details of how
that bill was defeated or what happened
to it I can guess however because we
still have similar issues the airline
industry opposed a lot of security
measures that people proposed before
9/11 now the airline pilots won't do
something where they want to move the
door back and have a second door further
back in the in the cabin and the airline
industry opposes that today they opposed
having pilots having guns
they've opposed a lot of it because it
costs them money and as we all know the
airlines are in tough shape financially
but if you have these regulations on all
airlines then they affect them all
equally and there's no competitive
advantage to anyone I saw this is a one
of the themes in the book how industry
pushes back on security regulations and
succeeds where the government usually
gives in to the industries that's
supposed to be regulating you talk the
book is about a lot of government
failures the bush administration has
made the case numerous times about the
fact that we have not been attacked
since 9/11 is this a success or a
failure
well it's obviously a success the
question is why is it why is it the case
it's not certainly because we've sealed
the border we haven't sealed the border
millions of people across the border
illegally every year so that's not the
reason it's not because we've made it
hard to get arms in this country whether
it's sophisticated handguns and other
weapons and bombing bomb-making material
or even radiological material those
things are all still kind of easy to get
here in this country I think it is in
part because the venue moved to places
like Iraq where we've had 4,000 American
dead and 25,000 American wounded so have
had 30,000 American casualties over
there admittedly not here but for the
terrorists we made it easy for them to
kill Americans over there and they had
the impression that we had made it hard
to come here Deer Park Washington is
next a Republican caller good morning
good morning gentlemen you're on the air
go ahead yeah the government has been
fabulously successful they created the
oxymoron and snafu and let me tell you
why Homeland Security let's see as an
American citizen I have to go through a
body cavity search to fly from Spokane
to San Diego but anybody can run
anything
they want up our southern and northern
borders anything and do you think
because the major national media doesn't
pay attention to this I had to flee Los
Angeles because of the Aborn illegal
immigration from everywhere in the world
but the media their own they don't want
to cover it the politicians they won't
speak about it so I will tell you that
the government has been seriously
successful they created the oxymoron and
the snafu thank you gentlemen
well I tend to agree with him the it it
would seem to me that if the United
States really was serious about homeland
security by now we would have had a
system we would have broken through this
difficult issue of immigration policy
and I think almost everyone almost all
reasonable people involved in that
immigration debate agree that part of
the solution is to really control the
borders and if we were really serious
about it we could do it people say oh
it's too difficult it's not it's not too
difficult you talked a little bit about
federal regulations this week's CQ
weekly talks about their cover stories
about regulations bigger picture and it
says America is no longer paramount in
the marketplace it may be fashionable to
deplore the decline of US military might
after five years of the war in Iraq that
has drawn upper Batian around the world
but it's also evident that as the global
economy expands US government agencies
are less and less able to supervise
financial activities get a handle on
domestic prices or monitor the safety of
all manner of imported goods just to
draw upon the latest latest headlines
why is that my point my point exactly
because we have developed this culture
in Washington and around the country the
government is bad and regulation is bad
and therefore regulatory agencies have
been filled with commissioners who
oppose regulation we have regulatory
agencies that don't want to do their job
so we had a mortgage meltdown because
the banking regulatory agencies didn't
do their job we have children licking
lead paint off Chinese toys because the
FDA doesn't want to do its job
and in the security area we have all
sorts of cases where the Homeland
Security Department and other regulatory
agencies have allowed industry to
determine what's adequate for security
next we go to Hayward Wisconsin on our
democratic line go ahead good morning
mr. Clark morning I admire respect you
and what you've stood for for all these
years I'm 79 years old and the problem I
have with our government for many
generations now is the obsession with
secrecy as an example I'd like you to
explain to the audience what you know
about the USS Liberty well the USS
Liberty was a little bit before my
government service sorry I really don't
want to speak authoritative Lee about
that but I am concerned as well about
secrecy I think the number of secret
documents generated by the government
has gone up successively in the last
several years there was an attempt in
the 90s to reduce the number of secret
documents and to reveal on declassified
documents from earlier years the trend
now has been in the opposite directions
that I'm not too sure no I I think it's
in part because they no longer believe
in the White House and elsewhere that
the government should be transparent
though that the public has a right to
know tie that into the chapter you have
in here on site the vulnerability to us
has to cyber security you know this is
another fascinating case like global
warming like al-qaeda before 9/11 where
we know there's a problem you know talk
to any expert Republican Democrat
there's a problem there's a problem with
cybersecurity and yet we're failing to
do anything about it until something
really disastrous happens and arguably
really disastrous things are happening
all the time the Chinese government has
hacked pentagon computers the Chinese
government has hacked the computers of
many large defense contractors
the United States and it's apparent that
the Chinese government or others could
hack into all sorts of things that
control important parts of our economy
they can steal our industrial secrets
they can steal our military secrets and
they could in a crisis do damage to our
electric power system and other
infrastructure if secure if secrecy is
such a high priority then why isn't this
being addressed I think it's again it
goes back to not wanting the government
to do anything if you're going to take
this new problem which no one's ever
really dealt with successfully before
and deal with it you have to deal with
private companies and you have to
regulate private companies because
private companies owned the electric
power grid and the banks on the other
infrastructure Haverhill Massachusetts
is next an independent caller welcome
hello you're on the air go ahead yes I
think we worry too much about other
countries and not enough about our own
country
all kinds informations constantly
getting stones from our country going
all kinds of foreign countries or these
foreign countries they attack us they
bad mouth off and here we go we give
them all our money it's totally
ludicrous I can't stand it I think I
think it's all bogus I mean you don't
buy friends yearn for one thing and
these people you know they give money to
terrorists then they give money to those
we don't give money to terrorists they
give money to Israel to fight back for
give the most money to all it's doing is
causing problems and their problems
ain't our problems all these countries
were giving the money to over there
Jordan and give me gives are the weapons
we give them they give to our enemies I
mean no garbage after 9/11 you see your
mafia threaten us what attacks and we
give money to Egypt I mean we really
need to start taking care of selves and
not worry about all these jerks that
backstabber Richard Clarke first of all
I think it's Haverhill since I grew up
in best I decided for it's always good
to get the geography right I think if
you if you talk about giving money to
other countries the United States
doesn't really
that very much as a percentage of our
economy were probably less in terms of
foreign aid and most industrialized
developed countries and when we do give
money usually not money most foreign aid
is tied to a program so there's money to
stop the proliferation of nuclear
weapons there's money to stop illegal
narcotics there's money to stop criminal
organizations there's money to stop
trafficking and persons particularly the
trafficking and women so if you look at
that
State Department foreign aid bill what
everybody likes to beat up on and ask do
you want to give money to other
countries everyone will say no if you
ask do you think we should spend some
money overseas to stop the proliferation
of nuclear weapons or to stop nuclear
weapons from getting into the United
States or drugs or illegal immigrants
then the answer is automatically yes do
you think we should give money to have
other people's police and intelligence
agencies stop al-qaeda rather than
having the Americans do it all the time
then the answer is yes and if you total
up all these yeses you get to about 85
90 percent of the foreign aid bill we
showed your clip a little bit earlier
about the 9/11 Commission and you were
apologizing to the families of 9/11 what
did you what do you write in your book
about the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina
how what was the government's failure
there the government's failure there was
almost complete and I say almost because
there was one agency that did a very
good job at that was the United States
Coast Guard and it did it instantly
automatically and without even reporting
to Washington helicopters from
throughout the United States Coast Guard
helicopters just moved because that's
what they do even from Massachusetts
helicopters moved and were replaced by
the Canadians Coast Guard but the
everything else in the federal
government failed to work and one reason
I believe was that FEMA had been
decimated of its experts and political
appointees had been put over how long of
a period did that happen it had begun in
2001 it had been true before and then in
the in the 1990s it was deeply
to a very large extent and then the
politicization occurred again but it's
also a failure of leadership lots of
different agencies at the state level so
you can weigh up a city level but also
in the White House
let's go to Annapolis Maryland on our
Republicans line good morning for
Richard Clark mr. Clark for your public
forum two points really one is I think
it's a bit unfair to characterize
homeland security as an abject failure
and the reality is is the federal
agencies just like their their governing
body above them in a democracy of a
commitment is well in other words a
representative is there's reflective
constituents and the constituents of
Bury therefore a single position and I
think this flows down into the agencies
the federal government god bless further
further public service we we have own an
agency to try and deal with and then
over a period of time it will do its job
thank you I hope over a period of time
it will its own inspector general the
last several inspector generals and the
Government Accountability Office have
given it goals and and given it grades
and it scores worse than any other
government department consistently on
all sorts of measures of getting things
done objective measures look there are
great people in the Secret Service and
the Coast Guard and ice but as a
department it's not working and that may
be because it's too big and we're asking
you to do too many things and therefore
the
is not clear it may be because it's been
given too much political pork to
distribute now that's the Congress's
fault not homeland security's fault
entirely and it may be because the
leadership frankly hasn't been what it
should have been you pointed out Coast
Guard was a success story for Katrina
they're part of Homeland Security mm-hmm
do you think the department should be
reshaped reformed as Coast Guard stay
with Homeland Security
again I believe that reorganizing
federal departments is something you
should rarely do because it takes
people's eyes off the ball that having
been said you know there are some
marriages that just really have to end
in divorce no matter how hard you try
because they really are unreconciled
differences and it's best when you know
that when you recognize that to get it
done our guest is Richard Clarke talking
about his book his latest book is called
your government failed you and we're
taking your calls for the next half hour
the numbers are on the screen 202 737
triple zero one for Republicans 202 737
triple 0 2 for democrats
202 6 to 8 0 to 0-5 for independence and
all others Cranston Rhode Island on our
Democrats line go ahead
Cranston go ahead I admire you as a
non-us person I have three and three
points to make I like for for you to
answer to me on the first question is
that many of us and many American people
marry Europeans feel that President Bush
committed war crimes in in attacking a
nation that did not pose threats by abu
gray Guantanamo Bay and killing our
soldiers be propaganda on the chokeman
that's the number one if you agree that
the international community should bring
him out after office for war crimes my
second point is that we all know that
the propaganda I have not even finished
high school then I admire you when you
came out and speak against the war
because I know you were saying is true
and me as a guy that
don't have much education knew the whole
thing is propaganda by seems to me that
propaganda still is moving on towards
your toes towards Iran and I was a
patriot a liberal and a McCain they
tried to put us in another war and I
liked to know that your opinion how much
gas will be after that and my third
point is that was up with our if you
support I know that you are support
Israel and we also support Israel by we
should be we should be little but fair
wonder fair handed and I like for you to
that who tell me if you support the 1967
bub treatment and if you support up for
the Israelis building settlements in
Easter in East Jerusalem because it
seems to me that the Lightning was very
serious about free Palestine and I think
personally that if we have two-state
solutions with peace over there I think
the tone of terrorism it will eventually
die thank you for taking my call Thank
You Rhode Island as I want their first
on war crimes about the Bush
administration I don't think we should
have the international community
investigating the United States
government but I do think we need to to
think seriously about some sort of truth
and reconciliation process in the United
States to see what happened on a whole
host of issues regarding the
Constitution and civil liberties and the
conduct of our foreign policy over the
last few years and maybe maybe what we
need is a an American government
Commission to see what happened and how
we might fix it
with regard to around we could talk
about that at great length but my bottom
line on Iran is before we use military
force
we better be darn sure that we know what
the result of that will be we utter you
as : Powell's doctrine which says among
other things you have to exhaust
diplomatic means and you have to know
what the endgame will be
I'm not at all sure I've heard anybody
explain what the endgame would be after
we used military force and finally on
Israel than the 67 borders I think the
67 borders form a basis for the ultimate
peace deal but I think there will be
some trading back and forth some
territory that was inside will be
outside and vice-versa but I think the
67 borders form the basis and then
there's the the knotty issue of what you
do about Jerusalem Detroit is next on
our independence line go ahead thank you
and good morning three points I want to
make first of all with the Israeli
problem I suggest people read a book
that they say is not real but it
definitely is like a blueprint of what's
going on today is called the protocols
of the learned Elders of Zion and I'm
sorry
secondly the the 9/11 attack you know
there's a information that Cheney took
over what is it called
the sec thing where the airplanes that
protect our ever-changing air command
yes
gg-get command they are for the first
time in the history of 50 years vice
president took control of that and they
haven't stand down during that time they
ran our tests and when once your third
point car and the third point was excuse
me that that kind of Detective bit was
that with the Homeland Security it seems
to ring like sort of like the program
they ran in Germany after they created a
false flag operation and burnt down the
Rostov they came up with the motherland
security which was basically you know to
police their own people like what the
seems like is happening here you know
that's pretty much it
don't let mr. Clark reply yeah I really
don't want to comment on any of those
things I think you know there are some
of these urban legends and terrible
myths that just float around about 9/11
on the other things and I just don't
want to give them any curve
see by talking about you run it at all
in the book about the role of Vice
President Cheney in terms of the
national security of the US yeah I do
I think the Cheney had a vast influence
and continues to have a vast influence
over the government in it was bigger
back when his best friend in the world
was the Secretary of Defense and what
the two of them were able to do was
Rumsfeld would take things directly to
Cheney Cheney would take them directly
to the president and the system would
never see them there's a reason we have
a system it's a matter of checks and
balances it's a matter of accountability
it's a matter of accuracy and oversight
and they cut out the National Security
Council system that Harry Truman
established in 1947 and then Eisenhower
expanded we have a national security
council system of we used to have one
anyway of nonpartisan people experts who
were designed to make sure that
everything was checked and analyzed and
there were options and they were
opposing views all that got cut out
you served President Bush until 2003 in
the National Security Council how how
soon did you observe this sort of
bypassing almost immediately you write
in the book about energy and one of your
chapters is about energy I'd like to
read a little bit from it because it
ties into some of the Senate debate
today in that Middle East war and in the
kernel and part of the rationale for
going to war which the notion that we
need to secure sources of oil it is a
simple argument for the public to latch
onto and it's largely wrong neither war
neither war was really about oil and
fighting a war tends to disrupt not
improve the flow of oil as I write this
in March of 2008 five years into the war
in Iraq oil is hovering above $100 a
barrel if the war was started to secure
cheap source of oil we have done a heck
of a job yet based on that false notion
we fight wars over oil calls are now
getting louder for the United States to
achieve energy independence something a
parade of presidents over the last 30
years have pledged to do then failed to
achieve in the global economy you write
achieving independence on anything is an
unrealistic goal pursuing it will be
costly in terms of dollars we'll do
nothing to improve our national security
and will distract us from the real
threat to our national security that
stems from our energy policies and
that's climate change the Senate's about
to debate a climate change bill today
why is that the real threat to our
national security well there's a lot of
myths in this issue of energy policy one
myth which I touched on briefly there is
the notion that we went to war in 1990
and in 2004 to get oil you don't have to
go to war to get oil no country that has
oil is going to sit on it they're going
to export it as soon as they export it
into the international marketplace it's
available and you don't divert oil away
from the United States it's in the
international marketplace we can get it
the other myth is energy independence
Richard Nixon was the first president I
could find who said in a State of the
Union address we will achieve energy
independence he said the goal of 1980
every president since then has set a
goal of energy independence means
meaning we don't import any energy well
every country in the world including
Iran and Saudi Arabia and Iraq and
Kuwait all the big oil producers every
country in the world
imports energy no country in the world
has enough of the diverse sources of
energy that one needs and the refineries
that one needs to be able to do it all
by themselves there's nothing special
about oil and gas from the United States
if it's more expensive to get oil out of
the ground in the United States or if
it's the wrong kind of oil then you get
it overseas there's also this myth that
by buying oil overseas were funding
terrorism and we're fighting both sides
funding both sides of the war on terror
people say it's totally untrue no one
has ever been able to document a case
where the countries that we buy our oil
from which are largely Canada Mexico
Venezuela Nigeria and Saudi Arabia that
those governments are funding terrorism
it's myth
the issue of climate change being a
security what makes climate change a
national security issue if climate
change occurs the way 90 percent 95
percent of the scientists believe it
will occur it will change the balance of
power in the world and we will be on the
wrong end of that stick our major
coastal cities will flood will have to
spend trillions of dollars to save those
cities
they'll be drought in other parts of our
country
another Dust Bowl as there as there was
briefly in the 1930s and we'll have to
spend trillions of dollars to move those
cities and to bring in water and to do
desalinization at the same time other
countries and Russia is probably one of
them will have their power increased
because certain parts of their country
that they couldn't use due to permafrost
will now be usable next color or Richard
Clarke is Buffalo New York on our
Republican line good morning good
morning mr. Clark first we want to thank
you for your service I'm a retired Navy
I retired in June of 2001 like you I was
called to service then my backgrounds in
aviation security I was they ended up
being a senior field director for TSA
during my time there I found that TSA
are many people who were unqualified or
simply were not wanted in the FAA for
one reason or another and as a result of
that I saw a lot of abuse mismanagement
people taking care of friends but not
taking care of public security and I
think this caused a lack of credibility
between the agencies my question for you
is do you have any hope that TSA will
evolve into a credible or respectable
agency and actually take care of public
security and it's specifically aviation
security for our nation if not what is
the alternative well I don't think
there's an alternative I think we have
to make it work
TSA was created overnight and went from
nothing to 40,000 people
less than a year and we did have to
scramble to find people and to steal
them from other agencies I think there
is inherent in its mission a problem of
quality control of the staff and they
have to be motivated and they have to be
trained and they have to be given decent
equipment and unfortunately the
administration has been talking about
cutting back TSA I think what we need to
do is make sure that they are better
trained and that their equipment is
state-of-the-art and that we put our
priorities in the right place having
everybody take off their shoes and all
that nonsense that we go through could
really be avoided and lots of these long
lines could be avoided if we had ID
cards if everybody had ID cards not just
people who are willing to pay $100 for
and if we had technology that could scan
more appropriately and quicker all
that's going to cost money and the
administration has been saying it wants
to cut back the budget of TSA well if
the American taxpayer is upset with TSA
unfortunately in the near term the
solution is to spend more money on it to
get it better technology and better
training and to get us all ID cards
rather than to cut back on it walleston
is next on our Democrats line oh good
morning mr. Clarke
I have to say that when you initially
came out and you spoke out about the
failures of the US government I was very
proud of you and I commend you for doing
that however my problem is and continues
to be is the culture of cowardice that
permeates and Washington and
unfortunately whistleblowers like you
like Scott McClellan and many other
people suffer from the same culture of
cowardice and the lack of courage which
is to speak about the central role that
the us-israeli relationship plays in
determining
u.s. security and have you're an
intelligent man I am sure you you know
you you watch bin Laden's messages when
they come out and bin Laden said quote I
thought about the idea of hitting the
towers in New York when I saw the towers
of Beirut being burnt by Sharon in 1982
that's number one number two since 2001
how many 9/11 in Arab human lives as
Israel killed its number two in number
three who were the most prominent
lobbyists in DC beating the drums of war
against Iraq after 9/11 ring thanks
Boston will give about mr. Clarke a
chance to reply well I think I said a
little earlier in the broadcast that I
really think that al Qaeda's propaganda
about Israel is a relatively new
phenomenon in in the second half of its
life as an organization and if Israel
and Palestine reached agreement al-qaeda
would still be around and still be doing
what it's doing there it's certainly
true that there were people who were
supporters of Israel who were engaged in
the propaganda and the lying prior to
the Iraq war it is also true that there
were many supporters of Israel's right
to exist and backers of the issue of
supporting Israel's security who were
opposed to the war like me there were
lots of us so I don't think you can say
just because there were people in favor
of the war and in the lead in the
propaganda who also supported Israel's
security that that was their motivation
why has been so difficult to the capture
bin Laden well in part because we're not
really focused on going after al Qaeda
to the extent that we should be after
9/11 it was the focus for about six to
eight months
then we started taking special forces
that were in Afghanistan out of
Afghanistan to get them ready for the
Iraq war and we took reconnaissance
assets that were in Afghanistan out to
get them ready for the Iraq war so long
before we even invaded Iraq we were
pulling assets off the search for bin
Laden and al-qaeda to get them ready to
go into a wholly unnecessary war in Iraq
now being an outside observer of the
National Security Council or our
security how would you gauge al-qaeda's
influence well al Qaeda's influence has
to be looked at regionally certainly its
influence in Iraq has diminished and
though in the last year or so I'd say
its influence in Pakistan and
Afghanistan has actually increased and
that tracks with the National
Intelligence Estimate and the statements
by CIA director Haydon general Hayden
and the Director of National
Intelligence Admiral McConnell they've
both said Iraq is reconstituting itself
Iraq is stronger al Qaeda is I'm sorry
al Qaeda is reconstituting itself in
Pakistan al Qaeda is now stronger than
it has been since perhaps 2000 to 2003
and that's because Pakistan has in
essence allowed a sanctuary to develop
in northwest Pakistan let's hear from
new orange from Orange Connecticut and
independent caller go ahead good morning
yes good morning I just want to point to
you the host I think it's you know first
o'clock I appreciate you and I believe
your intentions are good at leave
intentions all about this country and
any other country that you know talks
about doing the right thing but I wish
see spanning the host of c-span once you
do have a guest such as this particular
guest and you take calls and you say to
the audience we're going to take your
calls I mean be mindful that the callers
are on the phone but 15 and 20 minutes
waiting to ask the question every time
the call comes around to the person on
the other line to ask the question they
probably forgot what they wanted to ask
be sensitive to the callers and I think
the primary thing with c-span is that
this is the only program that we can
AskMe
learn and question facts so just be a
little insensitive to the callers at all
online but mr. Clark you've answered
most of what I wanted to know and I
already know most of it that Dick Cheney
is really the one who runs the White
House and the administration has lied to
the American public my one question I
like you to answer is based on what
you've observed McCullin him the
treatment of McCowen similar treatment
that you actually experienced yourself
do you can you tell me why he wouldn't
use the word that you used that they
lied well I think he actually has said
that though relies I haven't watched
every every show he's been on because
it's been on pretty much every TV show
and in the country but I think he has
said the word lie if he hasn't be
surprised because he certainly conveyed
the impression that they've been lying
and and said that they mislead people I
think he's been pretty clear about that
Dallas Texas a Republican caller go
ahead for Richard Clark yes mr. Clark
i-i've sit and listened to you and this
morning I'm very proud to be an American
with the exception of a couple points
you you write a book the how you have
failed us or how the government has
failed us but you in other end when a
man on the phone asked you a question
about a possible conspiracy or a
possible something in our country that
is happening that we are not being well
informed and that we are not gaining the
access to information that we should
have and that our civil liberties are
being taken away at the same point when
you say you have failed us or the
government's failed us and you were a
part of that you have to be more human
in the aspect that the internet puts out
information daily that is in abundance
that people can read should they want to
read should they want to find out
answers they can find out let me give
you an example you said the government
failed us in the aspect of a program
such as HAARP H a AARP you know what it
is it was probably in
in the time were being invented in the
time that you were in the White House if
it was not already being part I'm
suggesting that there are programs and
things that you say you have failed us
but you give us half-truths I don't know
why that is if you are going to step out
and write a book and say you fail this
then step out and write the book and
list them in chronological order because
some of the things you talk about in the
the government has failed you that you
only give us a taste for reading a book
I would rather read my Constitution and
know that it's being a rate of basically
eroded in its aspect because of things
you come out and talk
McCullen comes out and talked that's
wonderful but half-truths get us nowhere
if you failed line it up so we don't
fail again god bless america because
right now we're in trouble
because people only want to tell you
what they want to write a book for okay
Texas well look I entirely agree that
the Constitution has been abused in the
last several years Sheva liberties have
been eroded in the last several years
and I do in the book go through in
chronological order of the failures I'm
unaware of the H ARP program I will if
it's on the internet I'll go home and
look it up but I don't know what it is I
I don't think that we should have
half-truths you referred to a caller
earlier who asked some questions I
wouldn't respond to they were they were
at least two of them the popular myths
of the lunatic fringe and one of them
was grossly anti-semitic and was in fact
invented by Adolf Hitler and the Nazis
and I'm just not going to talk about
that I don't want to give currency to
that sort of thing next up is Roanoke
Virginia on our independence line for
Richard Clarke good morning good morning
what if you could comment in a personal
way about how all all of this business
that that was just brought to life by
Scott McCall of McClellan's a book and
the idea of the permanent campaign and I
wonder if you'd been inside and outside
of the
bubble that he talked about and if you
could comment in a way about how this
affected you at the time that you were
going through it and maybe to contrast
your work with both the Clinton
administration and and and then Bush
later on also could you tell us did Bush
did the Bush administration have it in
their minds to go into Iraq when they
came into office let me answer the last
part first I think senior officials in
probably including the Vice President
the Secretary of Defense and and a few
others senior officials in the in the
Bush administration I am convinced had
it in mind to go into Iraq when they
came into office I think the president
was not quite there but 9/11 kind of
pushed him over the top on that even
though they were unconnected he he saw a
connection and people saw a connection
and explained it to him and that there
was one when there wasn't on the
personal basis I think what Scott
McClellan is probably going through and
this notion of living in a bubble in the
White House I think it's true I think
when you when you work 18 hours a day as
senior folks do in the White House and
you work six or seven days a week and
all your friends that you get to see on
those rare occasions when you have time
off our people for the most part who are
connected to the White House you live in
the world of groupthink and you don't
understand
some of the dialogue that's going on
some of the perspectives that exist
outside the that bubble does it happen
in other agencies paper oh sure I think
it does but particularly in the White
House let's go to Chicago Chicago is
next on our democratic line good morning
for Richard Clark
good morning mr. Clark wanted to ask you
a question on a variation I wanted to
ask the Canadian ambassador to
Afghanistan earlier and that was you
know although there are in urban legends
and myths that distract from what is
doable and valuable
I found it useful back several wars and
bureaucracies to pay attention a shoe
joke to quipped to insult the graffiti
but sometimes tell you a ground truth
that doesn't always bubble up on the
cybersecurity end for example regarding
Windows XP there was way too friendly
for your own good
what kind of things if any are you
hearing that we out in the general
public are not getting that that might
be valuable that thick in the mind that
get the mind focused on it on a problem
directed toward a solution well on the
conspiracy theory thing I think what the
caller mentions about looking for
sources of information outside the usual
sources of information is very valuable
and I don't reject conspiracy theories
on at hand
in fact it was my job in the White House
on security related conspiracy theories
to check them out
and like I did with an open mind usually
99% of the time we were able to do both
them and I write about this in the book
there are a couple that we didn't quite
run to ground but I think you do have to
look at them and you do have to do what
the intelligence community calls open
source analysis look for information
even if it's just a little hint of
what's going on in unusual places in the
case of cybersecurity I think you pretty
much understand the problem operating
systems the applications are not secure
and I think you have to be very very
careful and you have to take
extraordinary measures to achieve
security it's a lot to ask for the
individual home user to do and you could
spend a lot of time trying to secure
your computer I think we have to take
that burden away from the average home
user
and try to have the the providers the
Internet service providers the the
Comcast's the Verizon's there have them
do a lot more of the cybersecurity
function does that have to be legislated
it has to be regulated the FCC has the
authority to do that now and it's looked
at it and of course the industry has how
old and therefore it hasn't been done
let's hear from Columbus Ohio on our
independence lawn couple more calls for
Richard Clark good morning good morning
mr. Clark is an honor to talk to you I
read your first book and I was
fascinated and I thank you so much for
coming out and and exposing some of the
things that you did two quick questions
scott mcclellan on Meet the Press
yesterday claimed in rebuttal but there
was a clip shown and critically
criticizing you strongly years ago for
coming out with your first book and he
claimed that he had apologized to you
personally recently I was wondering if
that was true and my second question is
I believe strongly whatever the
administration is next needs your
service sir
we need you involved in security of this
nation and I was wondering if you would
consider service under either a McCain
or a democratic undetermined nominee
administration I would like you to come
up to Columbus with a book to a please
I'd love to have you sign my book thank
you
yeah it is in fact true that Scott
McClellan and I met in a bizarre
situation we we were both apparently
staying in the whole same hotel in New
York last week and he literally came
through a revolving door let's start to
believe because of the metaphor but he
literally came through a revolving door
and bumped into me and we had a brief
chat and he did ask me to accept his
apology for what he had said about me as
a White House spokesman and I get I did
accept his apology I look I'm a big
believer in forgiveness and apologies
the 9/11 victims families forgave me for
my inadequacy in stopping the 9/11
attack and far be it from me not to
accept an apology so I did
last call for Richard Clarke st. Charles
Illinois
a Republican caller good morning go
ahead hi mr. Clark I agree with you a
lot of these callers they have been
troubling they've been deeply
anti-israel and as the you said deeply
anti-semitic but I want to ask you a
question about Hezbollah recently
Michael Chertoff and before him richard
armitage that Hezbollah actually is the
greatest threat to America and I sort of
agree with that because Hezbollah right
now has a state at its disposal
you know that's they've been Lebanon
being funded by Syrian and Iran
and to me that's the biggest threat
because they have legitimacy so-called
in an access to weapons and intelligence
that al-qaeda can only dream of
what do you think well I agree I agree
entirely I think his below is the most
capable terrorist organization in the
world right now has been for some time
much more capable has always been more
capable than al Qaeda that makes them
more capable Iran they are in many ways
an extension of the Iranian government
Richard Clarke's new book your
government failed you you're a professor
at the Harvard Kennedy School government
professor I'm a faculty member at the
Kennedy School of Government I'm an
adjunct and I teach a course up there
called national security management as a
as a professor is your view of
government now is that it half empty or
half full I think it's a way below half
empty it's it's it's at a low point and
I think no matter who gets elected just
changing out the president and the top
it's not going to fix it the new
president and that president's team is
going to have to do some institution
rebuilding Richard Clarke thanks for
joining us this morning thank you